se renseigner sur des formations
découvrir des métiers le principe des
traditionnelles portes ouvertes au
campus de l'automobile et de la mobilité
ce rendez-vous s'est tenue malgré le
contexte sanitaire les gestes barrières
et la gestion des flux des visiteurs
l avantage des journées portes ouvertes
en physique c'est de voir
l'établissement
les ateliers où on va travailler et
cetera c'est plus simple que le visio et
on peut poser plus de questions on peut
rencontrer des profs on peut rencontrer
les formateurs on peut voir tellement de
choses sur ce campus dédié aux métiers
de la mobilité quatre organismes de
formation le gard akla fort palier ncm
et le gnf à avec chacun sa spécialité
c'est important pour ce public de
pouvoir voir des démonstrations de
pouvoir se rendre compte de
l'environnement de travail qui va les
attendre pour permettre aux parents aux
futurs apprentis aux personnes en
reconversion de trouver leur voie de
s'orienter trouver la formation qui leur
convient dans l'automobile la moto et le
vélo l'institut national du cycle et du
motocycle et spécialisée dans la
maintenance des vélos et des motos
plusieurs formations sont proposées
allant du cp au bts en passant par le
bac professionnel des cursus sont aussi
proposés aux demandeurs d'emploi ou aux
personnes en situation de reconversion
on alimente nos énormément de demandes
sur nos formations en moto donc en
général quand ils viennent sur la moto
ils viennent par passion c'est leur
premier objectif
il veut leur absolument découvrir la
mécanique mais la mécanique vraiment
moto ou vraiment la passion de la vie
mécanique vélo un jeune qui faire un
contrat d'apprentissage ou un contrat de
professionnalisation s'insérera beaucoup
plus facilement dans une entreprise à
l'issue de sa formation
si vous n'avez pas eu l'occasion de
venir le samedi 30 janvier une visite
virtuelle permet de découvrir les
formations à distance sur le site
internet du campus